[Music]
welcome for many people one of the
things affected most by the pandemic has
been when where and how we work
for a lot of us it accelerated a trend
towards greater flexibility for others
it made them question what they want
from their workplace their employer or
their career
now as organizations address these
challenges to create a world of work
that works for everybody they may find
answers in some unexpected places today
we're talking about what business can
learn from entertainment from providing
greater choice and personalization to
the need to provide access on any device
from anywhere
to discuss these topics i'm joined by
fiona camanzuli people and organisation
network leader at pwc
carolyn horn emea president at workday
and timothy amu founder and ceo of
fanbites welcome i'm looking forward to
talking to you but we're here to talk
about what business can learn from
entertainment now it's not an obvious
connection sofia do you want to explain
the link briefly yeah i mean if we think
about the entertainment industry has
gone through enormous transformation so
it's moved from what we used to be used
to in the old days so fixed physical
media to now you know on demand
streaming entertainment companies really
thinking about their customers
preferences and actually using data to
try and understand their customers
better and then tailor content and see
much more personalization and actually
the workplace and employment is moving
that way as well so actually if you
think about you know people employees
actually now want to think about where
they work how they work you know what
they might be doing with their work and
what they're getting out of it and
actually i think it's really important
for companies to be thinking about the
preferences their employees have because
people actually want more choice it's
interesting uh what you say
fiona there's no question that you know
our lives have been transformed you know
both in at work and also in our home
life and i think it's only natural
that we would expect a same level of
personalization and choice in our
working life people are evaluating their
you know their their jobs at the moment
and thinking about what is it i really
want um you know from an organization or
you know for my career going forward if
you think about the
parallels of what's going on in the
entertainment or what has happened last
say 10 years it's almost that people
didn't realize that you could actually
just watch anything you want at any time
you want and now it's become the norm
and what covert has done is actually a
lot of people didn't realize that
actually you could work any how you want
and anywhere you want and so
it's almost as if the same
fascination that people had when things
like um
on-demand tv came it's like what i don't
need to sit down at 10 p.m to watch this
i can actually watch it at any point
that same fascination and that same
almost like
wonderment is happening in the workplace
and that's a pretty good space to be in
as an employer because you basically get
to i'd say like rewrite the rules
basically sometimes this topic can be
skewed towards people who can work
remotely but what about those industries
where people have to go to work how can
they transform
well i think there are lots of ways that
companies can think about how they
provide flexibility and think about the
employee experience so it definitely is
not just about people who are working in
offices or those who can work remotely i
think whether it's people working in
schools hospitals factories actually
companies can think about flexibility
around how they pay people what benefits
they provide what hours they offer and
choice around flexible working so
actually there's a lot of things that
companies can think about really broadly
to provide flexibility it's not just
about the whole question of flexibility
or whether you work remotely or not
because people are questioning now more
than ever what what am i getting out of
work what what is this experience
bringing for me and do you think
businesses are really looking at that i
i think they're starting to yeah and i
think that they are a lot of them are
recognizing um that
what their employees want is to be
really clear about
what the company's about so i think this
you know question of purpose and
articulating values i think that's
really important to people
of course there's a commercial aspect to
work for everybody
but i think that that is really really
important and i also think a lot of
companies are now realizing that
actually they've got to listen to their
employees more and they've got to
understand them and again another
another parallel with the entertainment
industry where you know netflix and
spotify they will use data a lot to
understand their customer preferences
and then understand actually what they
provide for them and tailor it and i
think companies are starting starting to
do that but they're gonna they're gonna
do it in different ways so how can
businesses and organizations create the
right culture um to inspire and motivate
their employees
i mean culture is just crucial every
employee all all the interviews i'm
doing at the moment you know
people are looking to come to a great
place to work that's absolutely at the
top of their mind they want to feel
empowered they want um an organization
that matches their their own core values
and really you know i think
culture is created by the whole
organization but really it does you know
come from the top and you know if i
reflect on on how we started our
co-founders they made a point of
interviewing the first 500 people when
they started up the company to really
try and embed that those right that
right culture their mission and their
values that would be inspirational and
motivational
and
and from there on you know really
driving that into the
setting that foundation and then driving
it into the organization
and then you know from there on before
the pandemic would bring together all
people leaders again to align on the
culture the mission and values make sure
everyone's aligned and then i think it's
empowering the people leaders after that
giving them the data and the insights so
that they're accountable to ensure that
every employee's experience is a good
one one of the things i guess which
might be slightly different is
at fan bites i think the average age is
probably about
23 or 24 right um because our whole
thing is you know helping brands to
reach a young audience so therefore have
a bunch of young people
and there's two key guiding principles
that we use to think about creating
culture the first thing is about
recognition so i think we are very
quick to recognize even you know some
more
somewhat simple things right and and the
reason why is because
for most people because they have so
much choice as to where they can work a
lot of it actually came to the
recognition that you're able to give to
your staff
and so i think that's a key thing about
like building a culture which is all
about can you give people enough
recognition where this is not just seen
as a job to be done for them and then
the second thing so a lot of my um
a lot of my employees
don't like you when they ask me a
question because my instant answer is
like you go figure it out
like every single time it's like right
so you go figure it out
in fact two days ago
someone actually asked me
so before i ask you this question can
you not tell me to go figure it out
and i said you go figure it out and they
came back and they figured it out yeah
um but the reason why i say that is
because one of the biggest things one of
the biggest things that i've seen
work so well is this idea of
giving people ownership over
the way that they achieve the outcome so
that to me has been a big managerial and
cultural shift that we've done i'm
always asking people
does it make the boat go faster so
anything you do i don't care how you do
it just like does it make the boat go
faster and those two things have been
two key drivers this recognition and
ownership of the inputs as long as it
gets to
the output i do think the leadership
the whole question of leadership is
really important because
organizations are a lot of them that we
talk to are moving away from old rigid
structures and again another parallel to
the entertainment industry where
you know becoming more networked and
becoming more agile and more fluid and
less hierarchical you know the point
around empowerment and that requires a
different type of leadership and and it
does influence the culture a lot so
thinking about you know organizations
think about what's what leadership
skills what human
you know traits and behavior they they
want from their leaders
to create that really good role model
because i think it is going to be
different to companies you know even
five years ago what sort of leadership
skills do you think work
well as you move forward then for me
empathy is probably one of the most you
know the ability to empathize the
ability to listen and to have compassion
i think are probably you know some of
the most important skills those real
really human traits that allow you then
to recognize the individual
um encourage
you know creativity encourage people to
speak up giving people courage the
continual listening to your workforce is
absolutely crucial but importantly
showing them that you're acting on that
it's not just you know the listening you
actually have to act upon it and do
something about it and
when your workforce see that you're
doing that and you're you're accountable
for that you really get that engagement
does that go back to personalization
about everybody is an individual and can
bring and contribute something to an
organization so it's just not one you
know one umbrella there's loads of
little factions and expertise within it
that you have to pick out and your
employees have to trust you to tell you
about it so that they feel comfortable
and they can explore that
for me it definitely goes to the
personalization piece but it also goes
to
actually being in a world where you've
really got to understand the person the
individual
and making a real effort to understand
individuals for who they are and i think
organizations you know as they seek to
build diverse inclusive cultures
it's important that they empower
individuals because that's how you
unleash creativity in your organization
it's how people feel
engaged and actually they belong and the
area it gives that connection employees
they need to feel connected in their
organisation they want to feel connected
to a culture that that suits them they
want to feel capable and back to all the
discussions around the learning and the
growth opportunities and they want to
feel cared for as well and if
organizations can
drive that through a really strong
employee experience then you know i you
know i think we'll be in good shape but
honestly can the experience of work ever
be like the customer experience is that
realistic
can we really have choice at work
i i do i do think it's uh realistic i i
think
you know with the use of technology we
we can mimic what we we've done in the
the entertainment industry and if you
think about the entertainment industry
and the stickiness of the fans that's
really what we want to create in the
workforce as well and have that that
stickiness for employees but it does
require you know good strong technology
in order for employees to really engage
in the organisation and
and and be invested and know that the
organization is looking after them they
care about their career they're offering
up personalised development
they're empowered as as you said to
merlier and and they feel in a safe
environment as well and if you have that
sort of experience with you know
consumer grade technology that will
allow them to engage from wherever they
are whether you know they're at home
working remotely or in the office i i
think we can get there
so if i think about the
the last time that i got into a good uh
show right um there was this idea of
just flow if you think about that
experience then the question is can you
give that type of experience to
an employee
and i think that that is entirely
possible because i do believe there's so
much choice in the world that people
would only stay somewhere and be in flow
and work for as long as it's benefiting
them and as long as they feel that they
are growing as long as they feel that
they're constantly learning new things
and i think for as long as people can
constantly feel like they're in flow
because they're always learning new
things and new skills and having new
experiences you would actually be able
to have a similar feeling of flow as
when you get
lost in a new tv show because you get
lost in the learning and the growth and
the oh this is new this is new this is
new this is something that i haven't
seen before if you look at a lot of
organizations they often collect data
about why people leave
and one of the most common reasons is
lack of professional development like
that that learning journey stops
and we were a long way from the times
when people had a job
from when they're 18 to when they're 65
so i think companies need to definitely
understand their role in helping people
through their whole employment journey
through their whole life and one company
might just be one part of that but
giving them the learning and the skills
i think the tricky thing for companies
is this question about
you know
we've we've been talking about giving
employees lots of choice but what we
haven't talked about is it's also all
going to be to the
to help the company achieve their
commercial objectives as well and so how
do you marry those two up because for
some companies culturally they might
feel more uncomfortable going to loads
of choice because they're like well
we've got to achieve these corporate
objectives so trying to work out how you
do that you know and
you know timothy what you said earlier
about
giving empowering people to sort of work
out how to do something themselves as
long as they can get to that end name
and i think that's something that
companies have to work through we really
need to focus that but again getting the
balance right because in the end you
know we've got company goals that we do
have to reach that's getting that
balance around really developing the
people but also you know delivering
against the bottom line as well thank
you so much um and i hope you've found
this discussion as fascinating as i have
i'd like to thank our guests for sharing
their insights and opinions and i hope
you'll also enjoy the other episodes in
this series exploring how business
challenges are better solved together